the tensions getting me our guard pay
I'm Ann Jones I host off-track which is
the ABC's nature podcast and today we've
got some saltwater crocodile videos I'm
hoping no one gets killed look at that
snout people say they can't jump right
and that's true because it's not like
they jump like this with their little
legs cuz you can't imagine like a
saltwater crocodile dog agility course
right because that would be hilarious
but they can propel themselves like that
one did that's got nothing to do with
the legs and everything to do with that
huge muscular tail he or she is using
that tail to propel itself up out of the
water you know like a synchronized
swimmer might do like Daniel on a donkey
just keep pressure keep pressure right
clearly they must be a crocodile there
somewhere I cannot see it yes Daniel
quick run back run back run back run
back he wants the fishy keep the
pressure Oh himself he looks to be fair
I don't think that that crocodile was
going for the humans it was going for
the fish the stats indicate that there
are maybe two attacks a year less
fatalities not that many fatalities a
year from crocodile attack but there's
things that you can do to avoid this
situation if you're camping make sure
you camp at least fifty meters away from
the edge of the water and if you're
going down to get water in a bucket or
otherwise make sure that you go to a
different spot on the river every time
so that you're not habituating that
crocodile turn know where you're going
to be
they're not great climbers are they look
at the size of its body compared to the
size of its little legs though right so
it's got a lot of you know weight that
it's trying to pull up they do have
pretty good claws and they can like I
have no doubt that the crocodile would
be able to get up there and we just
probably have a couple of gos they will
go in search of new territories say a
big croc comes along and forces them out
so they will go over land and up over
heels or it's called alligator head
that's not a good sign that's too many
though they are territorial right and so
if you're a big female or male crocodile
you will want to make sure everyone else
is out of your territory so you're the
one that eats all the barramundi unit
but when you're a young animal whether
that be a crocodile or otherwise they
often okay with each other's company
it's one of the ways you can form
relationships for example social
relationships maybe find a girlfriend
it's unlikely that you're going to be
attacked by a crocodile but it is a risk
and you should act accordingly it's your
responsibility you're not the crocodile
they're just doing what they know best
you
[Music]
so if you've got a video that you've
taken of Australian nature out there and
you want us to have a look at it and see
what we can see why don't you subscribe
and leave us a link to the video in the
comments we'll make sure that we'll get
to it soon